so the ball goes around the horn martine
perez looking to bounce back a little
bit he was very good two starts to go
against these royals he'll have his work
cut out right away because here is the
hot whit merry field he's into the
right-handed batters box
and wit swings at the first pitch and
squibs it out to second base and there
is marwin gonzalez
so one pitch one out against martine
perez
swung out of fly ball not hit deep
coming on to make the catch t.k
hernandez and it's a nice start for
martin perez red sox coming up mike
miner coming on for his 17th start this
year
his record six and five and a five one
two era
numbers not bad 91 in the third innings
88 hits allowed 27 walks and 94
strikeouts
that's wit
on the left side
so 4-3 to begin the bottom of the first
inning the 1-1 pitch hit in the air deep
center field taylor back still going
back at the warning track he makes the
catch and mike miner with a comfortable
one two three inning we head to the
second inning of play it's the royals
nothing and boston nothing right now he
is in a cool stretch and he's not facing
a guy that he's had great success
against one for 11 in his career the
wind and pitch and that ball is hammered
deep to left center field that's a way
back and that ball is out of here home
run for salvador perez number 19 this
year and the royals lead it one-nothing
2-2 pitch
and a good one caught on and missed he
struck him out his first k here's the
perfect change up for perez
the pitch bounced slowly past the mound
scooped up by gonzalez who fires to
first for the out so perez gives up the
home run to salvador perez and then
retires the next three
well the eight man marwyn gonzalez who's
at second base tonight will lead things
off here in the bottom of the third one
nothing kansas city
and line drive and a base head solidly
on one hop to olivares and that's the
first red sox hit and marwan not waiting
around yeah mauin's swinging the bad
betta from the right side of the plate
right now
so to abort for jd who's gone over one
so far he's flying to center now the
crowd and defends he get for something
to happen
stunned to center field backing up
taylor turning around
that's something happening
jd martinez with a three-run shot that
is the red sox 17th three-run homer and
his 2-2
through there for base hit off the right
center the shift cost him there
and xander picks up the knock i'd find
it very hard to shift on xander because
you just don't know what he's going to
do with the ball he can use the whole
field
line shot the other way that's high up
there and off the monster
xander bogarts will put on the brakes at
third into second base with a double
rafael devers
well you knew he was going to do
something you know he had some hit
something hard not about because he
missed his pitch bottom of the third
miner tried to keep it a 3-1 deficit
infield shifted around to the left in
the pitch fastball drill deep left
center field that's way back there and
that'll stay in the yard is michael
taylor right in front of the fence will
pull it down
and the inning comes to an end and mine
are able to strand bogart's endeavors
but a three-run homer by jd martinez
jorge soler leading off the fourth now a
fastball is grounded into right center
field that's a base in they had the over
shift around to the left he hit it into
no man's land on the right side of
second base and he's got a lead single
solar board
ground ball he's got it he's gonna throw
for one on the first double play how
about this
[Applause]
wow
he got him he strikes him out in the end
still three to one boston middle of the
fourth
to the shortstop and now in a rundown
gonzales trying to get back
dozier flips
marwin
trying to get back into second base will
peel off and he is out down to second
base
is chavis
swinging a high pop fly kiki might have
broken his bat it's into right center
field through the rain drops in on it
solaire and he makes the play to end the
inning we'll see whether we can keep
going here the grounds crew will come
out talk to the crew chief we'll figure
out what's going on three to one after
four
here's the pitch
and that ball struck to right field and
it's going to get down for a base hit so
o'hearn is on and the tying run will
come to the plate
ryan with his fifth hit of this series
and he gets the ground ball bogarts with
a difficult flip and gonzales is not
able to handle it so a break and the
royals have two on with nobody out
swing chopper to short this could be two
zander moore on that flip to gonzalez
and he turns it
six four three
two outs on to third goes ryan o'hearn
here's the two two on the way
swinging a fly ball toward that triangle
long long run for tk
oh he made the catch a sensational play
what a grab by [ __ ] he was running all
night long on that
and somehow with a sliding play
on the warning track up against the
bullpen he hauls it in so the first two
red sox have reached here in the fifth
inning zander's certainly looking like
he's headed for an all-star appearance
he'll hit a high fly ball into left
backing up backing up and that ball's
off the wall
verdugo rounding here he comes
he is in the score as he dives across
home plate red sox leading 4-1 ball up
the middle stopped by alberto he flips
the second for one on the first
merrifield could not turn it a nifty
stab but they can't turn two and it's
5-1 boston but the royals have them at
the corners here starting the sixth
inning
chopped out towards short and the play
will be to first
so mirrorfield scores it's 5-2
3-1 the pitch swinging a ground ball to
third nevers has it to second for one
over the first two double play inning
over and brandon workman just made an
enormous pitch
just one run comes in for the royals 5-2
after five and a half at fenway and
began to put the tarp on the diamond for
the second time tonight
first time since play began so we are
currently in our second rain delay of
the evening
after what will be close to a two-hour
delay we are getting set to resume the
ball game
and he gets a ground ball to the left
side dozier cuts it off
and throws on a hop and o'hearn handles
it
one away oh
nice play hunter dozier way to go way to
help out love lady there that'll bring
up hunter renfro in search of his first
hit
swing at a high
twisting deep fly ball and this one's
sailing totally out of fenway
red sox up six to two
and matt barnes as well his 35th
appearance 265 era coming on to close
this one out he was heated up
anticipating a save opportunity
o2 swung on and missed he put him away
back-to-back case and the red sox win
another one 6-2 over kansas city